[Music]
hi bo9 my name is olya my custom is what
where does all moons come from and why
does gas giants not have gas moves wow
that is a great question area Wow
first of all I was alive when people
figured out or satisfied themselves as
where our moon came from and it's
generally agreed that our moon was
created when the earth was hit with
another pretty big thing another
asteroid and the impact was very hot
very hard and the energy of the Smashing
was converted to heat and both the earth
and the moon were hot and molten and
they both cooled off and here we are
with this other separate thing in orbit
around us now why do gas giants not have
gas moons is a great question and the
answer is almost certainly because of
gravity so when you have these little
things that spun off of let's say
Jupiter or Saturn they were too small to
sustain themselves as just balls of gas
the gas shrunk down gravity pulled it
down and formed a solid thing whereas on
Jupiter and Saturn there's so much spin
so much heat created that they're held
in the gaseous state or what we call
gaseous state by the energy that's
coming out of them whereas the smaller
ones cooled off so much that they turn
solid it's just a fantastic question
Aria and astrophysicists or planetary
scientists speculate about this all the
time but what a fantastic thing that you
made this observation the moons of
Jupiter the big ones
io Kalista
Europa and Ganymede those big moons are
cooled off they're not they're not
gaseous like Jupiter that whom they or
what they orbit that's fantastic
Wow and maybe more will be learned about
this and I got to tell you Ari it's very
reasonable in your lifetime we will send
the right spacecraft to Europa and the
moon of Saturn Enceladus and Titan and
look for signs of life instead of being
a gas giant in this one example Europa
is a moon of Jupiter that is has twice
as much sea water as the earth and that
water is under a layer of ice and I
mention it because it's evidence of how
things cool off when they're in space
and they're small or relatively small
the ice forms because of the heat of
creation the things smashed together
that heat is radiated into space so
there's a crust of ice but the water
underneath is kept liquid by the
gravitational exercising of its orbit
around Jupiter
it's amazing what an observation aurea
you're making my day I hope you will be
involved in missions to Europa and you
will look for signs of life below the
ice I mean who knows if you have an
ocean for four-and-a-half billion years
things are going to happen could be
living things there could be your
opinions out there fish people that
you'll interact with keep us posted
thank you
[Music]